welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're going
to be breaking down Ridley Scott's Blade
Runner now which is widely regarded as
one of the most influential movies of
all time its Styles went on to inspire
so many different things in pop culture
and its Legacy has loomed large of a
film anime and video games ever since
its release it's something that I've had
a bit of a weird history with and after
feeling like it fell flat on my first
watch it's a movie that I've grown to
love more and more the more that I've
watched it the futuristic film Noir was
something I saw as a teen and I didn't
really understand what was going on so I
found it a bit boring this all changed
though after I read the source material
watched multiple documentaries and
engross myself in this fantastic film
world there's just so much going on with
it that they don't talk about in the
film and in this video I'm gonna be
explaining it all and also talking about
that ending there's so many hidden
details and Easter eggs laid throughout
and hopefully if you found the movie
boring this video changes the way you
look at it
based on the buck 2 Android stream of
Electric Sheep this Philip K dick
adaptation might be one of his best
known works because of how much of a
cult following the film has I think it's
one of those movies that catapulted the
author to the point where his name's up
there alongside Stephen King and that
he's someone who can go on the poster
alongside the director and cast Philip K
dick is a name that sells the movie and
everyone in Hollywood at some point has
been after some dick
sorry everyone in Hollywood at some
point has been after some Philip K dick
his work's been adapted into films like
Total Recall The Adjustment Bureau
Minority Report and many many more now
the name Blade Runner doesn't actually
feature in the book and this was
something that was brought across from
another science fiction novel that the
creative team owned the rights to
according to the now playing podcast a
Blade Runner referred to someone who
smuggled medical supplies like scalpels
in a dystopian future but they liked the
name because it just sounded cool which
to be fair it does now replicants are
also called Annie's in the book with
Deckard being a bounty hunter instead of
an officially sanctioned officer the
book gives a lot of the backstory that
isn't really touched upon in the film
and it's important to bear in mind that
this is a post-world War III World in
which a lot of the planets been
destabilized by an unnamed Global
catastrophe Earth is now highly polluted
and there's been major environmental
fallout from this which is why La looks
like London it's a far cry from what we
know the city to be like today and it's
constantly raining there and only ever
on to us at night to cement this idea
now in order to escape the Fallout of
the planet Humanity has ascended to the
stars and the un's encouraging off-world
immigration to several colonies that
exist on other planets in the bark they
try and lure people out there with an
incentive involving getting a free
Android and this will helply get the
species to leave Earth each human is
given one as a servant if you use the
discount code heavy spoilers at checkout
you get a free one and thus they can
live affluent Lifestyles amongst the
stars now those left on Earth do so
because a lot of them have either mental
or physical defects during the war the
toxin fumes that entered the atmosphere
cause people to mutate and this is why
JF Sebastian is rapidly aging there's
also gath played by Edward James almost
who has those iconic blue eyes and
several of the characters that we meet
have something slightly off about them
now there's this idea through our Blade
Runner that The Closer you are to the
ground the more impoverished you are we
don't even meet the people off world and
they're very much seen as being Neil
Elite you have to get an elevator up to
visit Tyrell and the blimps belong to
the corporations that now control the
planet even though the movie has flying
cars in it you might notice that there's
not actually that many and this is also
done for a specific reason the ones we
tend to see belong to the authority
figures like the police and Blade
Runners showing how they exist above the
majority of the population who have to
inhabit the surface you know the score
pal
you're not cops you're little people so
so A beautiful [__] of people riding on
bikes but in a futuristic world this
just denotes how much they're part of
the lower class now owning animals is
also seen as a symbol of wealth that
exists throughout the movie when the
toxic pollution hit the air this kill a
lot of the wildlife leading to almost
all animals going extinct because the
pollution spread throughout the
atmosphere are killed the birds are
first most notably the owls which we see
when are at tyrells later on press makes
his comment I'll be working in a place
like this if I could afford a real snake
and there's this idea that animals have
become replicants just like how the
humans have animals are given a lot more
emphasis in the bark with decadoning
replicant sheep that he keeps on his
roof Deckard is killing the Andes so
that he can earn enough money to buy his
wife a real animal which he eventually
does in the form of a Nubian goat
however this is killed by Rachel and the
story actually ends with their card
coming across a frog on a hillside which
he ends up taking home he believes it's
real but they discover that it's a
replicant however in the end they still
decide to take care of it that's a very
important theme that things lies
throughout the movie and the film
wrestles back and forth ever without
replicants are real or not in no science
fiction stories robots may look like
humans on the surface but once you get
below the skin you'll see their
mechanical parts and also the Machinery
that isn't really the case with Blade
Runner the replicants appear to be
humans both outside and in they are 99.9
perfect Cubby's reverse and the only
difference is that if he used a
microscope and zoomed in on their bum
you might see a serial number there or
something didn't know they were
manufactured to be honest though they
are identical to us except for one thing
the machines don't have empathy this is
what the void comp test carries out and
it's believed that if you ask a
replicant enough questions that over
time you'll realize they don't have
emotions thus Humanities very much been
able to separate them from us and
classify them as less than human because
they don't have a quote-unquote soul
eyes are said to be the windows to the
soul and throughout the film we get
several ties to them the void com test
takes a large focus on eyes and in the
scene with James Hong who watches
character Hannibal making eyes for the
replicants tyrell's eyes gleam out at us
and the character is killed by Roy
pushing his thumbs directly into them
hell the opening shot of the movie has
several cuts of eyes in it as we travel
through the sky and it's clear this is
important to pay attention to I think
the movie really asks the question over
whether replicants actually have souls
and in all honesty a find myself siding
with them of a decade and the other
humans it's important about in mind that
all of the replicants are slaves and
that they've been manufactured to serve
Humanity rather than being a part of it
the word robot itself actually comes
from the word Robotnik which in Russian
means worker or laborer it's basically
seen as someone who does all the heavy
lifting with very little else in their
life I think that the replicants
definitely carry this idea they were
used to colonize other planets and
explore the Hazardous Landscapes that
they contain so that actual humans
wouldn't be harmed when visiting them
they've all been given extremely short
life spans and the movie centers around
a group of them who've returned to Earth
in order to extend theirs they're
painted out as desperate and sympathetic
characters that clearly have emotions so
that we feel bad when we see them die
jokes are posing this Deckard doesn't
really come across as your typical hero
and in the movie the two replicants that
he takes out are women whom he shoots in
the back Zora's death is shun slow
motion and the way she falls makes
decades seem like he's just killed one
of the Hero characters rather than a
villain he chokes Rachel at one point
only lives at the end because Roy allows
him to and yeah he's not exactly a
stereotypical good guy descart is very
much meant to be like a replica himself
and that he isn't supposed to have
emotions and in killing these replicants
he should remain detached however we see
him drinking constantly throughout the
film and I've often seen this as being
because it's something that eases up the
guilty carries over murdering sentient
life it adds extra layers to the film
and it was also pretty clear to me on
this watch through that there were lots
of themes about God and creation laser
at it and that's a bit obvious but
there's a key change in the versions
that add something else to the Final Cut
bit of a tangent yeah but there were
several versions of this film released
with a theatrical Cup being what was put
out originally obviously this was Then
followed by a director's Curt before the
actual director's cook the Final Cut was
put out in 2007 reminds me of when you
do 50 different edits and you just put
Final on the end of the last one even
though you know you're going to be doing
about 15 more edits down the line anyway
the Final Cut has a slight change in it
when Roy visits Tyrell in the original
version he says
death
well I'm afraid that's a little out of
my jurisdiction you I want more life
[__]
well Cody says I want
father
it's an extremely subtle change but
altering [__] at her father is done for
a very specific reason father is a name
that we often use when referring to God
and this is Roy meeting his father now
playing pointed out of the film is laced
with this idea of killing our creators
and inhumanity creating replicants we've
now killed God because we don't need him
anymore we also have the biblical
imagery of Roy getting nailed through
his hand which seems to me to be a
pretty on the nose crucifixion nod
anyway the father line is barely
noticeable but it adds so much more to
the concepts in this movie and there are
some other changes in the film from me
the versions most notably the narration
which yeah if you've seen you can tell
Ford [__] hated doing it they don't
advertise for killers in a newspaper
that was my profession I didn't know
whether Leon gave Holden a legit address
but it was the only lead I had so I
checked it out it's so phoned in and
Ford originally had agreed with Scott
that there'd be no narration in the
movie according to the documentaries
Ford spent months with Scott working
things out so that everything would be
in the movie without the need for
voiceover however after the studio saw
the film they wanted some clarity added
to it because of how unclear things were
in the test screenings
board was called in to narrate and he
said in interviews that he went in
Kicking and Screaming because it didn't
represent Ridley's vision and it was
commissioned by people who had no
interest in showing that a separate
writer was hired to pen these scenes who
didn't know much about the film and Ford
said that he went in to shake his hand
in the recording studio but the guy just
ignored him what's wrong with Harrison
Ford so so his plan was basically to
record the lines as badly as possible
because he thought there was nowhere
they'd actually use them and I imagine
his surprise when they showed up in the
theatrical release four years he figured
he was wrong
Tyrell had told me Rachel was special no
termination date
I didn't know how long we'd have
together
who does
it does sound terrible to be honest and
when you hear it you can instantly tell
why the theatrical version is harder to
find than an iPhone that still has
Flappy Bird on it honestly though after
hearing it I kinda want Harrison Ford to
badly narrate my life all I could do was
sit there and watch him die now there
are some other small changes in the
theatrical and directors cut that was
put together in a great video by sticky
T it's 17 minutes long but some of the
changes include that forward space has
been digitally removed in a scene with
Tyrell we can also see a thumb on Roy's
shoulder in the phone booth and this is
because that was a flipped image from
later on in the movie deckard's lip sync
is corrected for the booth scene and we
also get a face replacement when Zora
dies so that the stunt woman swapped out
with a real actor there's some minor
differences to the Unicorn dream scene
and Roy is later added to the window of
the skyscraper to just create more
intensity in that scene lastly the
backdrop of the dove shot is slightly
different and in the Final Cut they use
the building that's more in line with
the skyline of this City now as for the
movie itself we start off far in the
future in the year 2019 what anyway we
learned that the advanced Nexus 6 models
started Mutiny on an off world colony
and since then it's been made illegal
for them to journey to Earth Blade
Runners have been tasked with quote
unquote retiring any models that journey
to our planet and the void comp test is
used to fish them out we begin our
overlooking the LA Skyline and this
effect with the fire and lightning was
done through using a miniature with
flames superimposed over the top of this
blame is of course chaotic and this
juxtaposes the rigid and immovable
structures that exist in La it's dark
Bleak and completely devoid of nature
stripping away any true beauty from the
world this is almost a hellscape with
flames very much giving us the idea that
summing terrible has happened in the
World to Change it to this
industrialized landscape as mentioned
earlier we get a close-up of an eye in
the scene and this is meant to symbolize
an All-Seeing Eye looking over
everything there's lots of things open
to interpretation here but I've always
took it as Humanity now being like a God
because they can create life and this is
is white but yeah the city is reflected
in the eye too and this shows what
Humanity's created with its Newfound
power we then see a giant pyramid with a
man in the window looking overall and as
we learn this as someone setting up the
void contest for Leon pyramids carried
out on subtext and they were owned by
the Pharaohs who ruled the lands of
Egypt slaves were used to build them and
all of the architecture that we see in
the film was likely built off the back
of replicants who were forced into labor
this man very much decides who lives or
dies and in many ways he can be seen as
a guard passing judgment on the
replicants however just like how humans
rose up into fight guard our Creations
are doing that too and Leon murders the
interviewer after being triggered by the
questions the questions here of all
rounded Torres being turned over on its
back which in the scenario Leon refuses
to help all of the vicom tests in the
film features some sort of animal or
whether it's a tortoise here or the WASP
later on and animals are actually
thought as being a way to teach children
an empathy from a young age decade asked
Rachel you're watching television
suddenly you realize there's a wasp
crawling on your arm I'd kill it this is
actually referenced later on in Blade
Runner 2049 when B lands on Kay's hand
but he doesn't kill it the void comp
test is also purposely set up to be
similar to the cheering test originally
called the imitation game this is a test
that measures whether a machine can pass
as a human or not it was heavily
referenced in the film X Machina and its
basis here is to see whether someone is
a replica or not Leon has also asked
about his mother a mother yeah yeah
let me tell you about my mother later on
we hear a repeat of the scene however
the tone is different
mother yeah
I'll tell you about my mother
[Music]
this shows that memory and emotions can
be affected and that they may alter the
way that we perceive things there's also
a subtle change in Leon's eyes now we
see that they sort of gain the
reflective gleam that the eyes of the
replicants are shown a later have this
is a sign that the facade is slipping
and that he's finally close to getting
caught now from here we go to the
skyline of Los Angeles and see a giant
Geisha on a billboard the city that we
see is highly influenced by Asian
culture including Neon Dragon signs in
the next shot Japanese umbrellas and
Street vendors that are out selling
noodles I've seen lots of theories about
what this signifies with one even saying
that this shows the World War was
between Japan and America according to
the theory the Japanese won and this is
why they're so heavily integrated into
everything other theories have said it
represents globalization and that it
plays into the idea of Asian superiority
which was appear at the time amongst
some circles this was during a big boom
in which many of our items were made in
Japan and China and this film was
potentially depicting the eventual
conclusion of this a Deck card can be
seen reading a newspaper and this has
the headline bombing the oceans the moon
and Antarctica these are all extremely
hazardous locations to visit and it
shows how much we've stripped the planet
of its natural resources below this we
can see a smaller one that reads
worldwide Computer Link are planned and
this actually predicted the internet
which wouldn't be made until 1989. in
the sky we can see a large blend but
advertising offwell colonies and this is
attempting to lure people out there so
that we can leave Earth Deckard grabs
and noodles which is when he's
approached by a police officer and Gaff
who speaks in a foreign language
he's saying you under arrest Mr Decker
this was actually invented by Edward
James Olmos and the language itself is
called City speak it's a mix of Japanese
Spanish German and English and it shows
how much the world has come together as
one with us all bleeding into this
Melting Pot now Gaff pretends that he
can't speak English throughout the movie
however we learn at the end that he in
fact can I guess you're through huh
finished
it's too bad she won't live
but then again who does
well there's a little clue that he that
he can as when he starts at the police
car he understands the English
instructions given to him
[Music]
Landing threshold a Deckard is taken in
by him and he passes a booth that says
vidphone which shows people were well
aware back then that we'd all be face
timing in the future in the car we also
see a screen pop up with Purge on it and
this is really Scott giving a little nod
to his prior movie Alien in which the
same graphic was used they traveled to
the police station and I love how you
can see other cars parked on the roof I
never really noticed this stuff until
the 4K Blu-ray came out and I definitely
recommend that if you love the film you
pick that up because there's so many
extra things you notice in the movie
just off the back of it now as old boss
Bryant reveals why he's being called in
and during this moment Gaff makes a
little origami animal gath is someone
who constantly torns Decker throughout
the movie and he even insults him when
using the city speak now this is because
he was the one who wanted the job of
hunting down the replicants and the fact
that Deckard was picked over him rubs
him the wrong way oh in the end he lets
both Decker and Rachel live and shows
them Mercy due to the fact that he
doesn't kill her instead he leaves
behind a calling card which is an
origami unicorn now eyes we see in the
movie decod has dreams about a unicorn
and this could indeed signify that he's
in fact a replicant as we learn in this
beautiful narration from the theatrical
cut four years he figured he was wrong
yeah the lifespan was changed in the
case of Rachel and there may be
something similar within him 2049 never
clears it up but let me know your
thoughts Below on whether you think he
is one or not personally I just prefer
the idea that we have a Blade Runner
falling in love with the thing he's
supposed to hate and it shows that
replicants have souls if she's able to
love him back we'll talk more on it at
the end of the video but the origami
could be seen as an indicator as to why
he's indeed an Android origami uses
man-made materials to form something
that's supposed to imitate an animal and
this is similar to how replicants use
man-made materials to imitate living
beings Gaff doing this could be him
further taunting Deckard and he makes a
chicken when he turns down the job this
obviously well he thinks he's a chicken
and later on he leaves a man with an
erection in Leon's apartment this is
after Descartes interviews Rachel and
it's been to show that he's attracted to
a replicant now the Unicorn comes at the
end which are promised to go more in
depth on but it shows these all have
their own meaning that ties in with
Deckard you could say the one with the
erection has its deck hard
sake I'll just leave
oh brother this guy stinks now Brian
shows Decor the footage of Leon's
interview and he talks about how six
replicants came to Earth but that too
got fried trying to storm tyrells this
is why they lady you Sebastian because
it allows them to go on as a trojan
horse and pass all of his security
measures any other versions the dialogue
is slightly different and it says that
only one got fried which led many to
think that decade was the missing fifth
one however this was more of a budget
issue and there was supposed to be an
extra person called Mary who was wounded
after they stormed tyrells they did have
scenes with her but they just never got
around to filming those bits and the
dialogue said that one died out of the
six until they changed it to two now
Brian shows the data that they have on
all the replicants and this includes
press who we learn as a pleasure model
the foreskin job is press a basic
pleasure model ironically she was
created on the 14th of February which is
of course Valentine's Day now pleasure
models are of course another word for
sex slaves and shows that the replicants
have been forced into every aspect of
their life we later learned that Roy is
in love with her and I've always kind of
view this as being similar to Spartacus
where we have a slave falling in love
with a servant and then rising up when
Bruce dies she spasms out on the ground
and this was meant to be almost like an
orgasmic death tying back to her purpose
Daryl Hannah is behind the pot and
Quentin Tarantino later referenced this
and Kill Bill when she arrives around on
the floor now at this point Descartes
sent over to the Tyrell building in
order to see if the test works on the
Nexus 6 that they have there it saw that
these new models might be so Advanced
that the test is now out of date and
that replicants will eventually hit a
point where they can outmaneuver it
Brian touches upon this and says that
the four-year lifespan was built in as a
fail safe in case they develop emotions
and start to rise up and disobey their
masters at tyrell's descard meets Rachel
and she asks him may I ask you a
personal question sure have you ever
retired a human by mistake
to me this is almost like a vitacom test
in itself because she's trying to see if
she can stir emotions out of him think
if you're killing people that are so
similar to humans that it wouldn't
de-cross your mind and with the test now
almost being obsolete it shows that
mistakes can be made now the book has a
doing something slightly different to
the film and descard stays with his wife
in the end even though he and Rachel
sleep with each other in a nice little
twist in that Rachel tells him that one
of the fugitive replicants is the same
model as her and thus he'll have to kill
someone that looks identical to the
person he's fallen in love with this is
somewhat touched upon in 2049 when a
version of Rachel is killed in front of
him now in the book Rachel admits that
she was programmed to seduce bounty
hunters like him so that she could turn
them away from their missions you could
see that as being something that's in
the movie too and with her being an
Android you might second guess whether
she actually loves deck or if she's
merely dissuading him from his job at
this point with me Tyrell played by Joe
Turtle he's someone who's featured in
our classic movie breakdown dance before
and you might recognize him as playing
Lloyd the bartender in Stanley Kubrick's
The Shining there was actually going to
be a major twist with Tyrell and I kind
of wish that they kept it in the movie
at the end when Roy killed him he was
gonna realize that he was a replicant
and then he'd travel up into the pyramid
and discover a tomb this was where the
real tyrell's body was housed and we
learned that he'd been dead for 40 years
this unfortunately never made it to the
film but I think it would have added a
great reveal to that final act that
might explain more of Roy's Madness
Tyrell and says I want to see it work
where's the subject I want to see it
work on a person I want to see a
negative before I provide you with a
positive
what's that going to prove
indulge me
he raises his hand almost similar how
Jesus would when pawning people which I
might be reading into but it's just
something I noticed anyway Rachel shows
how advanced that the new Nexus models
are and she takes the longest to fail a
test out of any replicant that's came
before her I think it's also worth
finding out that Nexus means a
connection or series of connections
linking two or more things these are
clearly the bridge between humanity and
machine and likely the next step in our
Evolution that will allow us to travel
further into the Stars once more the
questions are linked with animals and
she's asked about what she would do if
she was given a cat skin purse a Jar
full of butterflies and the WASP that we
talked about earlier the film is shot
with fade ins and outs showing how long
it goes on for with her failing the
final question about being presented
with a boiled dog at this point her
pupil doesn't change or alter showing
that she has no emotional reaction to it
and thus she fails the test Decker then
realizes that Rachel doesn't know she's
a replicant and he says respect how can
not know what it is again this ties into
the idea that Descartes could be a
replicant too and that he wouldn't know
if he was he doesn't really seem to have
a personal life and when we meet him
he's just sitting about with no real
discussion of his backstory it begs the
question of whether you yourself would
know if you were manufactured if
everything about you was identical to a
human if you were never told then you
could easily believe you were made
naturally which decade may be a victim
of now we discovered that Rachel was
never told that she was a replicant and
they created an experiment in her to see
if memories affected the machines Rachel
has had a real number done on her and
tyrell's even given her photos of her as
a child with a woman that she's been
told to her mother it's all used as a
way to control her behavior and these
experiences of the past enriching her
emotions which is why she can last
longer on the tests than the other
models Deckard and gath and travel to
Leon's apartment and hear the former
finds a snake scale located in the
bathtub we see Leanne watching outside
and then catch deck God going through
his belongings in the draw he finds a
newspaper and when he flips the cover
over we can see that this is the same
one that Deckard had at the beginning
this could show that descard is indeed a
replicant as he potentially came to
Earth at the same time that Leon did a
Harrison Ford was someone who thought
that Descartes should be human because
it shows that people can change and
accept the replicants deckard's a
character that's spent years killing
these machines and it's got to the point
that it's made him completely empty thus
the only thing that makes sense for his
character is for him to fall in love
with one which is the journey he goes on
throughout this entire movie however
Really Scott has always said that it was
his intention that descard was in fact
replicant which is why Clues like this
exist throughout the film Ford and Scott
didn't get along on set and both have
admitted that they actually hate each
other however they've said that they've
all put that behind them now but
obviously the question still hangs over
the movie as to whether decades are
replicant or not now we've seen the next
draw that Leon has photographs including
some of children which again is a
similar thing to Rachel E2 is being
given his false past and this is so that
he can pass the void comp test however
because Leon is aware that he's a
replicant he's not capable of lasting as
long as Rachel is now at this point we
see Roy whose hands slowly starting to
seize up which shows that he's dying his
first words are time
enough
and this is of course something that he
obsesses over in the film
time
to die now we cut to Hannibal Chu's work
room and we see him moving eyes out of a
container with Chinese characters on it
failed Mandarin at school but luckily
the internet helped me solve it another
smaller characters are gibberish the
large one means eternity or long
guessing this is saying that this is a
long lasting eye which is similar to how
we get long lasting batteries a Chu
can't help with longevity as he just
creates eyes but he points them in the
direction of Jeff Sebastian we discover
that Sebastian is rapidly aging and thus
he has some empathy for the replicants
to them both having shorter life spans
at this point descart returns home he
hits floor 97 in the elevator and then
when he goes to his apartment we can see
that the number is 9732 showing that
this is the 30-second apartment on the
floor Rachel has gone out to his home
and even though she shows him a photo of
her mother he breaks the bad news to her
he does this by correctly telling her
several of her memories including a
spider and its children that ended up
eating her these are similar to Deckard
streams of about the unicorn and again
it ties in with this idea of animals
constantly appearing throughout the
movie at this point we see how cut up
Rachel is about it and realizing that
she actually has feelings Deckard
pretends it's a joke it doesn't work
though however it shows decades starting
to see them as people rather than just
being machines she leaves and drops the
photo because she's now seen the truth
Anna's decided to not hold on to this
past decade picks it up and you might
notice there's a split second shot where
this photo actually moves and we hear
the voices of children
[Music]
now photos like this were used by the
corporation in order to trigger memories
and staring at one would bring the
implant back up this is why it moves and
it's doing this for decades could once
more signify that he's indeed
manufactured the photo also has writing
on the back and it shows the extent that
tyrell's gone to ensure the Illusions
kept up we then see press walking
through the streets which is when she
waited out for J.F Sebastian Prince then
runs off and she smashes her arm into
Sebastian's car which gives us this
hey
now Daryl Hannah actually said when
doing this and she ended up chipping her
elbow in a places she carried on the
scene though like a true professional
and being a pleasure model means she's
Adept at seducing Sebastian at this
point we once more see a blimp overhead
with a geisha on it I think the movie is
very much about accepting the other and
in many ways America accepting Japan
into their culture could be symbolic of
how decade accepts Rachel the movie is
asking the question over whether it
would be possible to do this which the
constant geishas could potentially
symbolize and we then see Sebastian's
home is filled to the brim with
mannequins and we learn that he lives in
this giant building all by himself this
is likely because most people have moved
off world razzies had to remain because
of his disease being lonely means that
he has made toys to keep him company the
replicants prey on the character's
loneliness from here we cut back a
Deckard who slumped Dara's piano and
this is the moment that he has the
daydream about the Unicorn interestingly
the Raw photos above it and these look
somewhat similar to the ones that the
replicants have there's two people stood
on the porch just like Rachel and her
mother and also some that look like
they're from the Victorian era these
could be showcasing that his memories
are in deep plans and that these photos
May potentially trigger the Unicorn
Vision he has Decker then decides to Sky
one of eon's photos and we get one of
the movie's most famous scenes now this
picture itself is somewhat of an Easter
egg and it's based on Jan van Ike's
Arnold beanie portrait both have a
circular mirror at the back of them that
contains a hidden detail and Deco
discovers Zora when looking at it he
matches this up with a scale and then
travels out in the city which is adorned
with Japanese signs swordfish being so
like a wet market and an eagle perched
on someone's head this is actually an
area where replicant animals are sold
which is why we later see ostriches
being moved through and ponies being
sold off Deckard goes to a snake seller
who eventually leads him to a dealer and
this is the person that points him in
the direction of Zora on the way we
catch geishas dancing with hockey masks
on once more showing the mixing of the
cultures Deckard drinks tonight away
drunk dials Rachel and finally Zoro
emerges as an exotic dancer with a snake
and this actually belonged to the
actress Joanna Cassidy and this is why
she felt so comfortable with it in the
scene realizing that descart is a Blade
Runner she makes a blade runner for it
which leads to Deckard chasing her
throughout the streets every person he
bumps into has their own religion and
culture this being a diverse Street full
of religions Lifestyles and all
different walks of life oop Atari symbol
at the moment you might know is that a
Deckard finally catches it with Zora
which leads to him shooting her in the
back as she crashes through some glass
as descart walks in closer to the hair
we can see mannequins dressed in
sexually provocative clothing and this
deliberately looks identical to the
clothes or is wearing right under her
coat these mannequins are all being held
up in glass displays and Zora crashing
through glass is supposed to be symbolic
to how they are here the glass boxes
with the mannequins in house these
sexual objects and they're there to just
be be consumed this is very much the
case in Zora 2 and even though she's
managed to break through the
quote-unquote glass box she was in she
was still killed now in the end her
deaths filmed like a tragedy and Deckard
is clearly shaken up by it Brian then
arrives and tells her that Rachel's done
a runner Blade Runner and then that
she's now being added to the list of
targets we see that the police number is
also 995 which I think my child at 911
has been changed but that might be a
reach anyway decar doesn't have to look
for up Rachel as he catches her across
the street however before you can go to
her he's grabbed by Leon who attempts to
murder him he does this by trying to
push his eyes in and this is similar how
Roy Kells Tyrell later on we know these
underwent the same combat training and
this is likely why they carry out the
exact same killing method Rachel saves
him though by shooting Leon in the back
of the head and from here we go to
descart and catch him drinking a shot
really nice bit of attention to detail
yeah and I love how the glass fills with
blood as he sips away showing he's still
leading from the fight with Leon now
this Barney sees more humanity and
Rachel due to her shaking after just
killing Leon Descartes says that he gets
his two and it shows that there's this
side within him that knows he's not just
killing machines Rachel asks if Deckard
ever took the test himself and again
this is meant to make us question
whether he's human or not Rachel goes
through the photos on his piano and in
the theatrical cut the narration tells
us that replicants are obsessed with
them they have such short life spans and
they take photos because it's a way to
hold on to their memories and show that
they were real via the nsays all those
moments will be lost
in time
[Music]
like
tears
in rain
and he's very much showing that they
need to take photos to record what
really happened Rachel changes her hair
after this and she opens it up in order
to mimic the photos slightly this could
be part of her programming to seduce
Deckard and at this point he's of course
supposed to be hunting her she plays the
piano perfectly and recalls her memories
of her lessons which are of course fake
and the pair get it on after this and we
then could depress spray painting her
eyes black she does this because she
wants to look like one of Sebastian's
toys and is now a fake person designed
to be real thing that's having to try
and look fake so that she can blend in
with the other creations she then goes
over to Sebastian and you might notice
that in the top right of the screen that
there is a unicorn this is the only time
that one appears in the movie outside of
the dream in origami and it could be
suggesting that because Deckard sees
this that Sebastian had a hand in his
creation Roy arrives and he says I like
him man that stays put
and this because Sebastian was someone
who wanted to move off world but he
failed medical and this is why he has to
remain behind we then see Sebastian's
chessboard and learn that he has an
ongoing match against Tyrell the board
is filled with animals and there's also
a giant ostrich calling back the ones at
the bazaar before Sebastian wants them
to show off their abilities but they
protest and say that they're more than
just computers Chris says I think
therefore I am and this is a phrase that
was first coined by the philosopher
Descartes he pondered whether his
existence was real one day and wondered
whether he'd be able to tell if this
world was a dream or not if it wasn't
then this meant that nothing he believed
truly existed unless he questioned
whether he really existed too however he
realized that because he's at least
thinking that he does indeed exist even
if he's out there in another reality
Imagining the world he now finds himself
in are they convinced Sebastian to take
them to Tyrell and Roy picks up two eyes
again calling back to this iconography
that appears throughout the movie and
they go to Tyrone which is when Ryan
struck Sebastian on how to beat him at
chess the shells that the Nexus models
have surpassed their makers and are now
capable of beating humans at everything
they run through multiple scenarios in
order to try and see if there's a way to
extend the life of the Nexus but all
attempts in the past have proven to be
fatal it's very much about how we can't
escape Our Fate and that in the end we
all must die Roy is referred to as the
prodigal son this again ties back to the
Bible and religion Roy kisses Tyrell
before killing him and Sebastian is
filmed standing behind candles which
resemble bars holding him back after his
cause almost robbed decados in the
Sebastian's building which is where he
faces up against press who becomes
almost doll-like again mannequins
surround this location along with the
toys that she's seen as being equal to
she almost kills Deckard between her
thighs again tying back to the idea of
her being a pleasure bot nadeka then
kills her and this leads to the final
showdown with Roy very over the top Bob
and Roy toys with him and breaks his
fingers after pulling his hand through
the wall Deckard takes a shutout Roy who
makes it seem like he's missed what
about we see in the next moment that his
ears in fact bleeding Roy monsora as he
gives Dakar a countdown to escape and he
taunts him through the scene by seeing
Opera and showing that he clearly
outmatches him Roy is very much just
spiraling into insanity and he knows
that even if he wins he still loses
because time is running short this very
much flips the script and we see the
hunter become the hunted as Roy chases
after him it's brilliant watching him
Howl at the Moon and run through the
shadows and it leads to one of the most
memorable scenes in cinematic history
now Ryan Deckard are meant to be
extremely similar at this point with
them both being badly wounded the pair's
hands are both seized up as well and
it's meant to show Decor that they are
both very similar on the roof Decon
makes a leap to another building and
though Roy could let him tie this point
he decides he has to save him though
Dakar has killed the woman he loves and
all of his friends Roy still pulls them
in and it's supposed to carry the
message of forgiveness the replicants
are better than we are and he of course
has a nail in his hand evoking images of
Christ and just like him he turns here
the cheek in order to become a savior
his final Act of life is to show pity
and this makes you question whether the
corporations hunting him were truly just
in what they wanted and Roy discusses
his life and he says
seeing things you people
attack ships on fire off the shoulder of
Orion
[Music]
I watched sea beans
glitter in the dark needed 10 hours a
game
it's something that really sticks with
you and it shows just how precious life
is Ruth gahau actually wrote this
monologue himself and the things
mentioned in it have been used widely in
science fiction for example the
tanhauser guide has popped up in a
number of different things and it
potentially pulls from Richard Wagner's
adaptation of the night tanhauser this
was a character that fell from grace in
the eyes of God potentially like how Roy
did with his own Creator either way he
dies holding a dove which he then
releases into the air as he passes away
symbolically doves are meant to
represent the human soul and him doing
this potentially shows that he did
indeed have one Deckard Witnesses this
completely blown away because he's just
seen that the replicants are indeed
Alive Now an important thing to bear in
mind about this movie is how language is
used to make it so that people seem less
than human for example they say that
replicants are retired instead of killed
because to kill something means that it
was alive you don't say you killed your
computer when you turn it off and this
is a similar thing when it comes to them
rice saying that it's time to die who
also means that he was alive too making
this a very important line Gap then
drops a line about Rachel and Deckard
returns harm to find her under a blanket
initially we are led to believe that
she's dead but gaffes allowed her to
live and this means that she and Deckard
can have a life together they don't know
how long that will be but they go on the
run and decode once more becomes the
hunted as they go out to some banging
synth music now I showed you the
versions before with the narration but
that's pretty much what was originally
intended for the film there was a lot of
shots of the hills and Countryside use
for this and they actually compiled a
lot of the b-roll from The Shining for
these moments Kubrick filmed a ton of
things for the intro and is Warner
Brothers own both they just decided to
save Scott some money and use it there
now we also know that they did have a
life together because of 2049 and that
the pair also managed to go and create a
daughter that's a breakdown for another
time but we do have the Unicorn being
left at deckards that we have to discuss
now the most obvious signifier here is
that gaffes used origami just don't
Deckard throughout and this signifies
that he's a replicant it ties into his
dream of the unicorn and is very much
Ridley Scott's vision of the ending
which has been left in the final card
because that's what he intended it was
also deleted scene with gap in which he
says are you really human it's hard to
tell around here and the fact he's
overlooking deckard's operations could
show that they don't fully trust a
replicant running around however he did
cut the scene and this could be to make
this ending more ambiguous Scott has
said that people can take their own
meaning from it and that he's not there
to say what's right and what's wrong
Harrison Ford also of course worked
alongside him to make this movie and as
we mentioned several times before he
thinks Deckard is human I go with that
more because it means that this movie is
about a person who's been tasked with
retiring these machines who in the end
realizes that there's more to them than
Mitzi there's not really that assessment
there if he's also a replica himself so
that's what I tend to side with when I'm
watching the film now the other way to
take it is that Gaff knows Deckard has
Rachel many views there as being a
unicorn to get a unicorn of course means
to get something unique and Rachel
itself has won because she has an
extended life span and takes longer to
fail the test than any other replicant
this could mean that descart has found a
unicorn and gaffes allowing him to keep
her as a sign of respect for completing
the job Descartes seemingly nods when he
sees it and whatever meaning it has he
understands why it's there and someone
accepts it in the end I think there's
probably enough things in the film that
you can really support any conclusion if
you look at it close enough and that's
also what I believe is the beauty of
Blade Runner one of the greatest films
ever made depending on what version you
watch the movie is influenced so much
and I hope you enjoyed going back
through it with us it's been great
seeing the response you guys have given
our going back through these older films
and if you want to see breakdown site
this early then you can become a member
at the channel for as little as 99 cents
a month that will get you these and
other videos early in advance that makes
a massive difference to the running of
the channel anyway I hope you enjoyed
the video and if you want something else
to watch then we have a breakdown of
really Scots of the Sci-Fi Masterpiece
alien linked on screen right now we've
also covered aliens as well so
definitely head over there to one of
them right after this by the way thanks
for singing through the video I've been
poor and I'll see you next time that
will be Blade Runner 2049 so make sure
you stay locked and have an awesome week
take care peace